القتال في محيط بخموت على اشده وبريطانيا
تحذر من امكانيه التقدم الجنود الروس الى
وسط المدينه التي ظلت عصيه على موسكو منذ
بدء الهجوم الروسي
الدفاع البريطاني هو حسب تقارير
استخباراتيه قالت ان روسيا استولت على
الضفه الغربيه للنهر بخمودكا وان الطريق
الرئيسي للامدادات في اوكرانيا معرض لخطر
كبير
وبالتزامن مع تشبث القوات الاوكرانيه
بباخمت وتصريحات الكرملين بان فرصه اجراء
محادثات السلام في 2023 صفر تتواصل الجهود
الدوليه لدفع الصين باتجاه انهاء الحرب
المشتعله منذ اكثر من عام الرئيس الفرنسي
ورئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه حث الرئيس
الصيني على اقناع روسيا بوقف المعارك
والجلوس الى طاوله التفاوض
انا ل
باس هي القاعده التي نراها بشان ما ندافع
عنه وما يتطلب الاستئناف المحادثات بشكل
سريع العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا وجه
ضربه للاستقرار الدولي اعلم انني استطيع
الاعتماد عليك لاعاده روسيا الى طاوله
المفاوضات
الرئيس الصيني وحسب رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ابدى استعداد بلاده لمحادثات
السلام والتنسيق مع فرنسا للدفع بقوه
لاجراء المفاوضات فيما اخبر رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه بامكانيه التحدث مع
الرئيس الاوكراني حاله توفر الظروف
المناسبه
التحرك السياسي في بكين لوقف نيران الحرب
في اوكرانيا تضمن ايضا وحسب مصدر دبلوماسي
فرنسي طلب من الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون
لزعيم الصين يقضي بوقف امداد روسيا
بالاسلحه ودعم سلام عادل يحترم سياده
اوكرانيا